what's up guys
you see how I'm uneasy then I walk on
stage to a comedy showing you like this
he's autistic is that a real thing or is
your friend a [__] well [__] dude
what do you do for fun man what's like
an autistic fun thing everybody being
uncomfortable [__] these guys dude I'ma
treat you normally
you break his balls about what his
autism no about how he's doing this the
entire comedy show every time hey man
you don't gotta explain nothing to me
bro you the first autist I ever had at a
comedy show
beautiful thing that's a beautiful
moment thank you for coming
the only thing to drink you want
anything to eat we'll put it on my tab
you're good what's your favorite food
I'm gonna go wrong with a burger you're
a [__] fascinating dude man I'm Hindu
you said that right to my face like I
said
[Applause]
it wrong with a burger like I'm Gonna
Know